sie trainieren für den ernstfall
amerikanische und polnische soldaten
gehen in stellung kämpfen ein flussufer
frei kurz danach rollen panzer und
transportfahrzeuge bringen nachschub und
geben deckung was die soldaten hier üben
die verteidigung der nato ostflanke die
us army überprüft und verbessert ihre
strategische reaktionsfähigkeit durch
diese multinationalen übungen so stellen
wir sicher dass wir gemeinsam mit
unseren nato partnern bereit sind und zu
verteidigen und mögliche gegner
abzuschrecken
rückblick im frühjahr beginnt das us
militär mit der größten übung seit ende
des kalten krieges defender 2020
zehntausende us-soldaten sollen nach
osteuropa verlegt werden insgesamt 18
nato staaten beteiligen sich doch dann
ende märz bringt die korona pandemie die
übung zum erliegen alles stoppt bis
jetzt dank umfangreicher
quarantänemaßnahmen kann zumindest eine
übung im westen polen stattfinden
zuvor wurden alle 6000 soldaten auf
corona getestet gerade hier in polen
beobachten sie die aggressive politik
russlands und wladimir putins ganz genau
und sind froh mit ihren amerikanischen
nato verbündeten trainieren zu können
insgesamt zwei wochen lang werden die us
truppen in polen üben bevor sie dann
über deutschland zurück in die
vereinigten staaten reisen
das manöver in polen begleitet hat mein
kollege maximilian kiewel er ist auf dem
truppenübungsplatz im westen polens
zwischen stettin und danzig max sind
denn auch deutsche soldaten beteiligt
die bundeswehr sollte eigentlich mit ein
paar hundert soldaten aus minden hier an
dieser übung teilnehmen aber aufgrund
der korona partie hat man sich dagegen
entschieden die quarantänemaßnahmen und
die isolation die wir für die anderen
soldaten gehört haben die wollte die
bundeswehr hier so nicht machen oder
konnte sie nicht machen spielt der
us-truppenabzug den tramp angekündigt
hatte eine rolle
der us truppenabzug aus deutschland ist
so hier die rechtlich angesprochen
worden aber was natürlich ein thema war
die enge beziehung die amerikaner obwohl
mittlerweile haben die amerikanische
botschafterin für polen ist hier mehrere
generäle und dass wir schon mitbekommen
haben ist wie eng diese allianz
mittlerweile ist und wie sehr sie gelobt
wird wie sehr auch die polnischen
counterparts gelobt werden von den
amerikanischen politikern und generell